we've seen a reasonable number of acid
reactions and base reactions so let's
just write down a few of them for review
and let's see if we can see a general
pattern here and a lot of this might not
be any news to you so if we have
hydrogen fluoride or if it's in an
aqueous solution its hydrofluoric acid
we know that this is a weak acid it
doesn't disassociate completely so it's
in equilibrium some type of equilibrium
that doesn't mean the concentrations are
equal these this hydrogen disassociates
then sometimes it'll well actually we
know in reality it tags a ride-along
with another water molecule and forms
hydronium and then you have and then of
course this is still aqueous everything
is going on inside water and then you
have left over your fluoride anion or
negative negative ion and that's also an
aqueous solution well we could have
rewritten actually let me write another
reaction here just so you can see the
general pattern let me write a another
acidic reaction let me write ammonium so
that's nh4 plus it's ammonia with an
extra hydrogen and then let me just
write that in an aqueous solution that
can disassociate to one of those
hydrogen's popping off in an aqueous
solution and then you have ammonia nh3
that's also in an aqueous solution now
both of these describe an equilibrium
reaction but it kind of implies that
we're dealing with weak acids right you
take an acid and they're producing
hydrogen which is at least the rainiest
definition of an acid if you looked at
the bronsted-lowry definition where
they're donating protons to the solution
they're creating hydronium the donating
protons to the water around it but it
kind of describes it as a as an acid but
we know it's a weak acid so this
reaction goes in two directions so we
could write the same reaction
essentially is a basic reaction so we
can instead of saying hydrofluoric acid
azar
is our acid we could say hey if I just
have a fluoride anion if I just have a
negative fluoride here I could say a
negative fluoride if I put that in
actually I keep I keep making that same
mistake fluoride the the fluorine does
not have an L in it I do that because
chloride does so I should let me erase
this so there's hydrogen fluoride as HF
so it's just f their periodic table so
you always confuse fluorine with
chlorine right because F is just for
fluorine but you get the point okay so I
could rewrite the same the same acid
weak acid equilibrium as a weak base
equilibrium where I could say a negative
fluorine anion in an aqueous solution is
in equilibrium with and now we're saying
I'm considering this a base which means
that it's going to increase the
concentration of Voyage so what this
might want to do is it might want to
grab some hydrogen from some of the
water that's in the aqueous solution so
it grabs some hydrogen so it grabs some
hydrogen and becomes hydrogen fluoride
or hydrofluoric acid let me do that in
the in that magenta color its aqueous
and where did it get this hydrogen from
well it got it from one of the
surrounding water molecules which was
h2o since it gave away one of the
hydrogen's now it's just Oh H - so the
surrounding water molecule is Oh H minus
aqueous now these might look different
that you know this head this is creating
this is creating a you know this is
donating a a hydrogen to create two to
the surrounding medium to it and then
you or you're left with just the
fluorine molecule while this is
essentially creating a hydroxide
molecule out of the surrounding medium
so it looks basic but if you think about
it these reactions are the same I mean
you could have just gone in reverse
direction you could say hey this is
going to react with some random
hydronium molecule or some random
freestanding proton out there and then
it could it could form hydrogen fluoride
but we know that hydronium is
just sitting everywhere that when
whenever you take the reverse reaction
whenever you're going in this direction
this doesn't have to grab this hydrogen
from an h3o it could grab it from an h2o
and then you would have this reaction
these are equivalent and we could do the
same thing we could do the same thing
here for ammonium and ammonia we could
say we could write ammonia as a base and
a ch3 is in equilibrium as a weak base
with it can grab a hydrogen from its
surrounding medium and become NH 4 plus
in an aqueous solution and then it would
have grabbed that hydrogen probably from
a water molecule because that's what's
around it and so that water molecule
will become an O H minus and so now this
looks ammonia is a weak base ammonium is
a weak acid but these are equivalent
reactions now you're probably already
seeing a relationship here ammonium is a
weak acid ammonia is a weak base and
what's the difference between the two
just an H right let me and hydrofluoric
acid is a weak acid just a fluorine cat
an I on the negative fluorine is a weak
base and what's the difference between
the two they're just difference of a
hydrogen let me write that down so we
have let me write weak acid weak acid
and then you have your weak base weak
base so your weak base when we write our
weak acids first we had hydrofluoric
acid and then the weak base is when you
essentially just dumped the hydrogen
just the hydrogen proton you kept the
electrons so that's why it's a negative
charge right there
right hydrogen without it's one electron
is just a proton because it has no
neutrons
the other one was NH NH four plus
you dumped one of the hydrogen's and you
get nh3 so what's the difference going
on your these are all minus a hydrogen
or if you go this way you're plus a
hydrogen right so
with you have these these kind of
conjugates and this is um this is all
been a long-winded way of introducing
you to this idea that you have these
conjugate pairs like hydrofluoric acid
or hydrogen fluoride and just the
fluorine anion so these are conjugate
pairs conned you get conjugate pairs
which are essentially two molecules that
are identical except for a difference in
one hydrogen no more than one hydrogen
you might one day there might be a test
where someone shows you two molecules
that are separated by two hydrogen's
those would not be conjugate pairs for
example for example if I show you h2o
and Oh H minus these are conjugate pairs
because this has this over here is
exactly this minus a proton and in fact
let me be clear that it's not just minus
the hydrogen minus the proton right one
of them is keeping the electrons so this
is minus a hydrogen proton this is plus
a hydrogen proton so the difference
between these two are just a hydrogen
proton now so these are conjugate pairs
now if I were to say that h3o and O H -
you might be tempting to say hey this is
very acidic this is a base this is a
conjugate pair but no there's a there's
a there's a - h2 proton difference so
this is h3o plus there's a two proton
difference so these are not conjugate
pairs not conjugate pairs now so let me
just cross that out but these are now
you could say if you have h3o you might
say hey what's the conjugate base and
that's a new word I just introduced you
to what's the conjugate base for h3o if
h3o is an acid well you take one h from
it and you get h2o so this is a
conjugate pair conjugate pair and I just
said a word without defining it so now
let me define it within every conjugate
pair you have an acid and a base and if
you say Oh what is the conjugate base
for
hydrofluoric acid you get rid of a
hydrogen and you say oh it's just this
fluorine this fluorine anion if you said
I have some ammonia what as a base what
is its conjugate acid so if someone asks
you what is the conjugate acid you add a
hydrogen proton to it and you get
ammonium so this is so that I could call
these the conjugate acid let me just
change terminology conjugate and we'll
see that they actually you don't have to
be using a weak acid or a weak base
conjugate acid and then you have a
conjugate base and even though something
might be a conjugate acid or conjugate
base it doesn't necessarily mean that
they're very basic for example or very
acidic if I have hydrogen chloride we
know this is a strong acid hydrogen
chloride its conjugate base we
essentially just get rid of one of these
hydrogen protons it doesn't take its
electron with it so it's just going to
be the chlorine negative ion this is its
conjugate if you asked if I gave you a
chlorine negative ion I said what's its
conjugate base you say oh so what's its
conjugate acid you say its hydrochloric
acid if I gave you hydrochloric acid and
I say what's its conjugate base you get
rid of a hydrogen proton only and you're
left with the chlorine negative I and
you say that's its conjugate base now
with that said we know that when you put
a hydrochloric acid we know this
reaction this was I think the first
reaction we looked at an aqueous
solution it disassociates completely to
form hydrogen protons plus chlorine
anions everything of course in an
aqueous solution now the fact that it
disassociates completely that this is
not an equilibrium reaction this implies
that this guy is more basic than water
he has he has no temptation no no let me
let me say that he is less basic than
water
he has no temptation to grab these
hydrogen protons from from the
surrounding medium to
to reform hydrochloric acid this
reaction does not go in this direction
so even though this chlorine anion or
negative ion of chlorine is a quote
quote unquote conjugate base conjugate
base of hydrogen of HCl that doesn't
necessarily mean it's that basic this is
less basic than water
it wants the hydrogen protons less than
let's say hydronium so if you put some
chlorine plus some hydronium or let's
say just some you have some H+ you're
not going to reform hydrochloric acid so
this is not not really basic even though
it's considered a conjugate base but
most when you and that's generally the
case whenever you're dealing with strong
acids so like in the case of
hydrochloric acid if I had a big
solution if I had a big solution of just
chlorine anions in water so I just had
tons of a high super high concentration
of chlorine anions and water because
it's not going to do anything to change
the actual hydrogen or hydroxide
concentration in the water because it's
it's more basic than the water sorry
it's less basic than the water itself it
doesn't want to take or give anything to
the water the pH so if you have a soup
the pH would be 7 if you have chlorine
chlorine minus in an aqueous solution
and I don't care what its concentration
is you could have you could have you
know you could have 10 molar of it the
pH is still going to be 7 because it's
not going to change its solution it's
not going to change the pH just this by
itself now obviously if you put
hydrochloric acid in an aqueous solution
this will change it because you're going
to be dumping all of these hydrogen
protons into the solution so in general
I mean you can kind of remember it but I
think it's maybe common sense that a
strong acid strong acids conjugate base
is neutral in water neutral so that
means no impact on pH no impact
on pH all right you say chlorine you
know plus h2o I mean you're essentially
still going to have chlorine plus h2o
you're not really changing the
concentration now on the other hand when
you're dealing with weak acids so this
reaction will go in the other direction
if you put some fluorine in water put
some fluorine in water it will grab some
hydrogen not you know not necessarily a
ton of it but it will grab some hydrogen
from the surrounding water and increase
the hydroxide concentration right it's
increasing the concentration of this
thing right here so it is making in this
case it is making the solution more
basic it's in its it's increasing the pH
of the solution so whenever you have a
weak acid whenever you have a weak acid
weak acid its conjugate conjugate base
will be a weak base weak base and you
could make this statement the other way
around if you have a conjugate con let
me switch colors it's getting annoying
conjugate conjugate base sorry a weak
base its conjugate acid is going to be a
weak acid so hopefully you get the idea
here it's actually not that fancy of an
idea it's just that if you have a acid
its conjugate base is just that acid
minus a hydrogen if you have a conjugate
if you have a a base its conjugate acid
it's just that thing plus plus a
hydrogen actually let me just do a bunch
of a bunch of problems here just to just
to really hit the point home of what
we're talking about so if we you know
let's let's just do a bunch of them so
if this is the acid and this is its
conjugate conjugate base so if I have I
mean you don't even have to know the
words if I have that the conjugate base
well I'm just going to get rid of a
hydrogen proton so no.3 minus I didn't
get rid of the whole neutral
hydrogen molecule remember I just took a
proton away the electrons tell you the
same so I have a negative charge if we
already did let's say we did h2 so4
so it's conjugate base get rid of a
hydrogen hso4 minus if I have hydrogen
bromide get rid of a hydrogen it's BR
minus and this is a this is a strong
acid right so this is going to be a
neutral way if you put this in water
it's really not going to do anything
even though you do you are calling it
hydrogen bromides conjugate base now if
we go the other way if we give you the
base if I give you Oh H - what's its
conjugate acid well you add water you
add a proton to it you get h2o if I have
h2o we already did that you had a proton
to it you get h3o plus if you have I
mean we could just keep going if I have
let's say I have that if I add a
hydrogen to it I have h2o
there you go it's neutral now because I
added a proton anyway hopefully I
haven't beaten this horse to that then
you understand what conjugate acid in
bases are all about